malaria has a huge impact on the human
population it affects people throughout
the tropical world this is a devastating
disease and while there are treatments
to it diagnosis is difficult there is an
adequate means for diagnosis and
treatment is not universally available
so people are dying it's impacting
livelihoods throughout the world this is
one of our most important public health
crises of our time really is malaria in
the case of malaria there was some
interesting information that was out
there that there was a parasite just
like the major human malaria parasite
falciparum plasmodium falciparum that
was in chimpanzees but there was only
one example of this and so people
weren't really able to say too much
about the relationship of this parasite
called Plasmodium reckon owie and the
human malaria parasite which was the
most deadly one plasmodium falciparum
and so basically what we did along with
colleagues at the rubber Koch Institute
and at University of Massachusetts
Amherst as we went out and we actually
looked in chimpanzees and we tried to
find evidence this parasite and we were
surprised that whether it was in cote
divoire in cameroon we were actually
able to find chimpanzees were infected
with this parasite
for me the sort of the the real aha
moment was recognizing wow these these
parasites are out there in chimpanzees
one of the things i started to convince
myself of was that perhaps you know
because i assume people would be out
there looking for these things so if
they hadn't found him i figured they
must be very rare and the answer was
really people just were not out there
looking for them and i think that was
one of the sort of aha moments for me
but but the other thing to point out is
that this kind of science is hugely
collaborative so the number of aha
moments and sort of Eureka moments in
the science there was a bunch of them so
there was that one there was also the
work in in dr. Steve riches lab at
University of Massachusetts Amherst
where he actually saw sequence from
these sorts of things and put them
together and realized lo and behold all
of the diversity of humanities is held
within the the sort of broader diversity
of these parasites and chimpanzees and
that really was like we sat down at a
table and looked at this data and we
were like you know what there's no way
to interpret this other than really
being the movement of a chimpanzee
parasite into humans and you know of
course we sort of looked at each other
and and and it was it was pretty it was
a pretty incredible moment
as a young kid I remember vividly and I
must have been probably four or five
years old and I was watching I'm pretty
sure it was National Geographic
documentary with my father on work that
was done with wild gorillas in in
central Africa and that's sort of the
the most of my recollection that I have
but I remember just being sort of
incredibly fascinated with the idea that
these you know that these animals were
some of our closest living relatives and
I think that was at least for me the
first sort of sense i had at the the
sort of wonder that we have the
potential to have with scientific
inquiry to change the way that we think
about the world and to grasp insights
that sort of afterwards appear somewhat
obvious but beforehand are you know are
really quite opaque and basically how
that information can change the way that
we think about ourselves and ultimately
empower us
by studying these things and obviously
it's important to study them I don't
think you get a good sense of what it is
like to actually be a scientist and so
maybe part of it is is increasing the
interface between students of science
and actually an actual scientists
because I think for many of us we we
feel very fortunate to be in this
endeavor where despite all of the
complexities and difficulties and not
enough funding and heavy competition and
all these sorts of things that really at
the end of the day we get to go out and
ask questions about the nature of
reality whether it be life or the
universe or soil or whatever it is we
get to ask these questions and if we get
lucky we get to we get to find some
answers and there's a certain thrill to
that which is I think among the more
intense thrills that that were capable
of as human beings and I think that all
of that that sort of the thrilling
exciting element of it is somehow
missing actually exposing students to
real science might might might might
radically change the the courses of
their careers and increase the number of
people that are out there trying to do
science
this is really about about interacting
with scientists it's it's challenging
you know to be a scientist many
scientists are not are not compensated
at the levels that they should be
compensated funding is difficult often
we enter science and we we basically end
up doing things that are different than
what we originally envisioned but at the
core of it most practicing scientists
out there have something that they
really really love about what they do
and their capacity to answer real
questions about life and about the world
and I think sort of exposure to that
excitement and an understanding of sort
of what it means to be a scientist and
some of the some of the sort of great
elements about it might very well change
the way that you know that people think
about science and increase the number of
people that would go go into science
you